welcome back to cbs mornings at 7 30.
much of the west as you know is in the
grip of a mega drought and lake mead in
particular this is near las vegas is
showing the dramatic effect of falling
water levels this is the nation's
largest reservoir and it's now giving up
many of its formerly submerged secrets
including another set of human remains
this is the fourth such discovery since
may alone
david malkov chief environmental
correspondent at our partners at the
weather channel now shows us how long
lost stories are emerging
daniel kolod is one of those people who
went missing in lake mead in 1958 the
retail manager at the desert in hotel
was on this speed boat with his best
friend my dad was 22 his buddy mike was
23 and i think it was more
boat than they could handle the accident
was just too far from shore and too deep
at the time
but as you can see the mega drought of
the past two decades has dried up huge
sections of the lake the human skeleton
that could be daniel collad showed up on
may 7th not even a week before a woman
found a body in a barrel my initial
thought was the old story clips of
when you hear about organized crime and
stuff like that it's getting a little
too hot former las vegas mayor oscar
goodman is now retired but decades ago
he was a lawyer who represented powerful
people in old vegas
he played a version of himself in martin
scorsese's mob drama casino completely
absolves mr rusting from any wrongdoing
in the old days when i was actively
practicing i had one client that they
said murdered 27 people specifically you
don't think that this body in a barrel
is moderate no no well we would have
heard if it was mob related why drive
all the way out
and put somebody in a barrel they would
want people to know it it was to teach a
lesson instead the lake itself is
teaching us all a lesson about how fast
climate can change draining a massive
lake of all its secrets we believe that
that barrel was at one time under
approximately 150 feet of water i never
dreamed i would see the lake this low as
the drought intensifies these bodies are
returning from the past all someone's
son
daughter
or possibly father if i could wave a
magic wand and erase the impacts of
climate change and drought and make all
that go away i would gladly take
having my dad's remains be lost forever
it just isn't worth it for cbs mornings
at lake mead
dave malkoff the weather channel
dave a body in a barrel is a little
troubling it really doesn't get into a
barrel by itself
it doesn't that's it's very sad news it
really is a lot of questions for sure